let's talk about gay pride up in seattle
it is gay pride month
very exciting there's a whole month
devoted to gay pride
spectacular stuff now it's going to
involve reparations because
you know you can't you can't just be
proud of who you are without grifting
some money
off undeserving people uh we've got some
quotes here from
770 ktth radio organizers for a seattle
gay pride event say they're
changing white charging white people a
quote
reparations fee to attend they have the
support of city council president and
mayoral candidate
lorena gonzalez and the seattle human
rights commission
taking black pride organizers
say all are welcome to attend however
white
allies and accomplices must pay the
reparations fee
it will be charged on a sliding scale of
10 to 50 dollars depending on one's
ability to pay
critics question whether race-based
admissions
fees are appropriate seattle municipal
code
clearly prohibits racial discrimination
but organizers have pushed back
calling criticism of their admission
structure
casual violence god these people
are complete racist idiots now first off
what's hilarious here is this is a gay
pride event right
so if you were gonna charge people
reparations
wouldn't you be charging straight people
not white people
but for some reason they're charging
white people i mean if we were at least
keeping this in the somewhat box that
this thing's supposed to be in if you're
at a gay pride event
and then straight people want to come i
wouldn't be for this but it would be
like if you want to charge
the straight people more but no they're
making it about white
people because intersectionality is the
greatest idiotic moronic grift
of all time and makes everyone who even
dances with it for a moment
just that much stupider so these people
are the ones who want
systemic racism imagine if you're just a
white person
so that means what that means is you
could be a white gay guy
right you're a white gay guy and you
show up to the to the black
uh pride of it and it's like hey guys
i'm here for you i want to celebrate
and it's wonderful we're all gay and
lesbians and stuff
like okay can i come in and they're like
well how much do you earn because we
gotta
figure out how much you're charging it's
slightly scaling well i'm a test
instructor so i don't know
can i do 12 dollars it's like well you
know is your boss white what do that do
it's gonna be 15
for you
you